momento de hablar de economía france24
por ello le doy la bienvenida a mi
compañera daniela blandón daniela
empezamos en américa latina' cómo se ha
comportado el desempleo en la región
tras un año de pandemia andrés muy
buenas noches el primero le cuento a la
organización internacional del trabajo
calcula que en la región se han perdido
alrededor de 26 millones de empleos por
culpa de la pandemia hay tres países que
mensualmente presentan sus cifras al
tiempo aunque allí se puede ver también
pues el deterioro del mercado laboral en
general estos tres países son primero
colombia en donde la tasa de
desocupación pasó del 12,6 al 14,2 por
ciento aproximadamente en apenas un año
3,4 millones de personas en este país
están sin empleo casi 500 mil más que
hace un año el otro es chile el primer
trimestre de la tasa de desempleo siguió
en dos dígitos como a lo largo de toda
la pandemia aunque está lejos del
histórico 13 1% ha anotado en agosto
pasado y hembras y el desempleo no sólo
sube frente a un año atrás sino frente
al trimestre anterior el 14,4
de la población no tenía trabajo al
cierre de febrero estos son unos 14,4
millones de personas en términos
generales andrés parece que la región
sin embargo está mejorando o por lo
menos la cepal elevó al 4,1 por ciento
su perspectiva de crecimiento para este
año desde un 37 % proyectado en
diciembre también la economía de europa
entró de nuevo en recesión sí señor el
producto interno bruto de los 27 países
de la unión europea cayó 17 por ciento
anualizado en el primer trimestre frente
al trimestre del año anterior debido a
los lentos lanzamientos de vacunas y a
los bloqueos prolongados de esta manera
la región queda todavía más rezagada con
respecto a otros pilares de la economía
mundial que sí vieron crecimientos
vertiginosos en el primer trimestre
comparado con el año pasado cuando
apenas estaba iniciando la pandemia
estamos hablando de china que creció un
18,3 por ciento y en eeuu que acaba de
revelar que lo hizo en 6,4 por ciento
los países a los que peor les fue en el
primer trimestre
a euros o ven a frente al mismo
trimestre del año pasado fue portugal
españa y austria y la sorpresa positiva
vino por el lado de francia
daniela vamos a hablar de bolivia porque
acordaron el aumento del salario mínimo
el gobierno de luis arce y los
dirigentes de la central obrera
boliviana acordaron subir un 2 por
ciento el salario mínimo nacional lejos
sin embargo del 5 por ciento que pedía
en estos últimos al mismo tiempo
decidieron que no habrá incremento del
sueldo básico de contratación que es el
salario de prestación de servicios el
salario mínimo en bolivia hoy andrés es
de 2.122 bolivianos o sea unos 307
dólares en 2020 no hubo aumento por la
pandemia y en 2019 el entonces
presidente evo morales dispuso subirlo
en un 3 por cierto con el alza de ahora
el salario quedará en dos mil 165
bolivianos unos seis dólares más lo
curioso de todo este asunto es que los
empresarios llevan años sin participar
de esas negociaciones
también vamos con una noticia bastante
curiosa y es que la fiscalía de italia
investiga a un albañil por ganar dos
premios seguidos de lotería como espera
pues la historia elaboró el afortunado
es un hombre de origen brasileño que
trabaja como albañil en verona al norte
del país el 4 de febrero se ganó en
raspa y gana de la lotería estatal por
un millón de euros pero despertó
sospecha cuando la suerte lo volvió a
acariciar 20 días después esta vez por
dos millones de euros medios italianos
como este que vamos a ver corriere del
véneto dicen que los investigadores
sospechan que habría habido una
filtración fraudulenta de noticias por
parte de algunos empleados de la
automática que es la concesionaria de la
lotería estatal ellos habrían filtrado
supuestos cómplices una serie de
información ultra secreta permitiendo la
supuesta hazaña pues una jueza de verona
ordenó el embargo del premio hasta que
se aclare la situación del nuevo
millonario ya quisiera podría ser una
persona afortunada yo creo que podríamos
porque no
momento de conocer los indicadores
daniel westling cerró con pérdidas en
sus principales índices aunque al cierre
de abril acumuló más del 3 por ciento en
ganancias las bolsas europeas cerraron a
la baja por los malos reportes sobre su
economía y en américa latina las bolsas
cerraron hoy en rojo pero lograron
buenos avances en el consolidado de
abril
d'angelo hablando como siempre con la
información económica muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y ustedes muchas gracias
por sintonizarnos quédense con toda
nuestra programación